Homes and buildings reduced to rubble.
Now, dozens of search and rescue teams are desperately digging through mountains of debris,...
...looking for any signs of survivors.
Good Samaritans use their bare hands to pull this woman and a young boy to safety...
...after they were buried under this collapsed building.
The quake has killed more than 1,400 people and destroyed thousands of homes,...
...and now, there is a race against time...
...as a tropical depression is threatening to bring heavy rains...
...and major flooding to areas hit hardest, which could hamper rescue operations.
The epicenter of the 7.2 magnitude quake struck near Les Cayes,...
...a coastal town located about 80 miles from the capital of Port-au-Prince.
This is just another major setback for a country that hasn't fully recovered...
...from the 2010 earthquake that killed an estimated 220,000 people,...
...and a nation still reeling from the assassination of its president Jovenel Moise,...
...just over a month ago.